today at the Matt Walsh show states are
beginning to reopen but churches are
still being unfairly and more
importantly unconstitutionally targeted
for extra restrictions that make no
sense at all some churches are finally
stepping up to defy these restrictions
but what took so long is the question
also 5 headlines including CNN
continuing to be clown itself what else
is new and in our daily cancellation we
will cancel the designers and
manufacturers of a hospital bed that
doubles as a coffin yes I'm not making
that up we get to all that on the show
today but we start here and it's about
time we start to see this in Minnesota a
number of churches Catholic churches
mainly but also lutheran churches some
other churches are gonna open up in
defiance of the directives from their
state's Emperor Tim waltz now opening up
in general is is not the act of defiance
technically they're allowed to open they
have been magnanimously generously given
permission to open by the emperor but
the defiance is because they're opening
at 33% capacity at least that's what the
Catholic churches are doing which is
quite a bit more than the 10-person
limits that Emperor waltz has decreed
emperor waltz has said if you're a
church you're only allowed to have 10
people at a time here's the crucial
point the emperor is allowing retail
shops and malls and other stores like
that to open at 50% capacity restaurants
are allowed to have 50 people in their
outdoor seating area churches though can
only have 10 ok now try to make sense of
this for me if you can because I I can't
quite understand it most churches are
quite a bit bigger than restaurants and
many churches are as big or bigger than
big-box retailers or even malls and but
they could only have 10 people so what
is is the social distancing rule for
churches now like 60 feet between people
instead of six have they multiplied it
by 10 it doesn't make any sense unless
you take it for what it is which is
an assault on religious liberty and that
in fact is what this has been from the
very beginning not just in Minnesota but
across the country we have to understand
something in order for this to be an
assault on religious liberty it doesn't
have to be that governors are plotting
against churches as part of some kind of
anti religious scheme now I think there
there probably is an element of that in
a lot of these states but I think that's
not really the point what what this is I
think in most cases is governors who
subjectively because he or she is not
religious just doesn't think that
churches are that important or essential
as they say no and so these governors
don't think it's worth the risk to have
people go to church they just don't
understand why is it from their
perspective and this is this is they've
been very clear about this all along
from their perspective it's it's like
why would you even want to go to church
in the first place why would you want to
risk anything to go to church so I'm
doing you people a favor I as the
emperor of the state as the governor
turned Emperor I don't see why anybody
would want to go to church is not
important to me and so why should it be
open now Walmart okay
that's worth the risk but I can
understand as a consumerist myself I can
understand why you would risk it to go
to Walmart or Best Buy or even Outback
Steakhouse sure to get the bloomin
onions okay you're gonna you're gonna
risk it for that but for church now who
needs churches that's the attitude I
think and it amounts to politicians
closing churches and keeping them closed
on the basis of their own opinion of
churches and religion and that is
clearly unconstitutional that is clearly
an attack on religious liberty and it
has been as I said from the very
beginning we'll have more about this in
just a second but first a word from
helix sleep you know when we're spending
as we all are so much time with the kids
these days you're especially wiped out
at nights I know that I am I mean not
just these days but in general if you
have young kids you're gonna be very
tired and getting a good night's you
also don't get a lot of time when you
have young kids you don't get a lot of
time allotted for sleep and you never
know you know some nights you might get
five hours other nights they might give
you three depending on what that means
when you get that time however much it's
very precious and you got to be able to
sleep and that's what helix sleep will
help you with helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm if you sleep on your side
or on your back or in your stomach or
your your very hot when you sleep
whatever it is with helix there's a
specific mattress for each and
everybody's unique taste and you can
find out what that is and get the
mattress for you just go to helix sleep
comm slash Walsh take their two minutes
sleep quiz just start with that and
they'll take it from there right now
helix is offering up to $200 and free
pillows with all mattresses for our
listeners at helix sleep comm slash
Walsh
that's helix sleep comm slash walls for
up to $200 off your mattress order go
there now okay you know what the other
thing to keep in mind though we when we
talk about the church issue we talked
about this idea of essential versus
non-essential the point about religion
is whether you think that religious
religious worship itself is an essential
activity and I believe that it is but
whether you do or not the point is that
the right is essential it is an
essential right essential essential in
the deeper sense of the word not
essential like important and that's what
we when this word essential has been
tossed around so much and places have
been shut down or allowed to stay open
based on it it always just means
essential as in important important to
whom
well the according to the governor it's
important to us but really it's
important to him and so he's the one
deciding but that's not what we're
talking about there's a deeper sense of
the word essential essential doesn't
just mean important that means it means
inherent to our nature so the right to
practice our religion is
in that its inherent to our nature and
that's what it says in so many words in
the First Amendment and that's what the
fad our founding fathers believed and
that's the idea
that our country was founded upon we
have allowed over these past two months
the government to redefine religious
liberty as non-essential which is
another way of saying we've allowed them
to define it out of existence because if
a right is not essential then it isn't
inherent and if a right is not inherent
then it doesn't exist that's what human
rights are they're essential to our
nature if they're not essential to our
nature that we don't have them it's not
then it's it's at best a privilege and
that's indeed how these tin-pot dictator
Zinn governor's mansions see religious
liberty and that's how they want us to
see it now churches in Minnesota are
finally stepping up and saying enough no
we're not going to go along with this we
are going to exercise our rights with or
without your approval because your
approval is irrelevant you know they're
saying we're gonna open up the way that
we think is safe because it's not like
we're a bunch of suicidal nihilists
quite the opposite we're not try to get
anybody hurt but we think people have a
right to worship and they need to it is
essential and so we're gonna open up
we're gonna do it in a safe way but we
are we are gonna decide what is safe
that we don't need a bureaucrat or
politician to tell us the safe way to do
it we'll decide that's what the the
bishops in Minnesota are saying the
churches are saying the question though
is whether it's too late has the damage
already been done the fact is that
churches all across America with few
exceptions obeyed allowed themselves to
be closed submitted to a ban on public
worship think about that okay a ban on
public worship let's not get to the
point where we're so used to the to the
idea that it doesn't shock us anymore it
should shock you even after all even
after two months it should shock you
there was and still is in this country a
ban on public worship in America in a
country that was literally founded to
escape that sort of tyranny and churches
most of them went along with it now
they're not good why did they ever is
the question from what I've read and
some of the emails I've gotten a lot of
you know Police Department Sheriff's
Department's around Minnesota are saying
they're not going to enforce this
so these churches they they they are not
gonna go into churches and start and
start hauling people away in cuffs
they're just not gonna do it they're
gonna refuse to well you know and and if
they don't which which which I think
they will refuse to because well what
are they really gonna if you've got
churches all across Minnesota open are
they really gonna march into hundreds of
churches and start hauling people away
in Chains no they're not gonna do that
they were never gonna do that so you
call their bluff successfully could have
done it from the beginning what's gonna
happen now I'll tell you this is
eventually we can we can look to the
horizon and we can see one of the most
important Supreme Court cases that that
will be before the court in the next few
years and that's gonna be but could be a
case about you know centered around this
idea of whether or not the government
has the authority to define religious
worship as non-essential and depending
on who wins in 2020 and depending on
what happens you know I I don't have a
lot of confidence that they're gonna
come down on the right side of that I
mean imagine it's the Supreme Court
depending on what its makeup is by the
time a few years from now by the time
this this this a case like this appears
before them imagine the Supreme Court
actually codifies into law and says yeah
you know what a religious worship is not
essential imagine the ramifications of
that virus or no virus pandemic or no
pandemic that's that's essentially the
end of religious liberty in America okay
let's go to headlines number one
big news here folks Joe Biden has
finally come up with a nickname for
President Trump speaking to the Asian
American and Pacific Islander victory
funds progressive summit that's what it
is Biden said Trump is out there
tweeting again this morning
I call him president Tweety yeah see
this one is disappointing for me
personally from Biden I was expecting
something a little bit more old-timey
maybe like Donald the dunderhead yes
something like that
I just I don't think President Tweety
lives up to the expectations that I that
I had and by the way Trump's nickname
for Biden sleepy Joe is is also super
lame creepy Joe this is one of the
biggest missed opportunities in in
modern politics you go with sleepy Joe
rather than creepy Joe it's it the two
words rhyme creepy is a lot you know
when you think of Joe Biden do you think
oh that guy is super sleepy what what a
sleepy guy that guy he is
no you think hey guys creepy that's
what's a weird creepy dude I mean even
you know even senile Joe would work I
mean something like that I just think
sleepy doesn't doesn't work perhaps more
to the point though even even aside from
all that we should remember that these
men are in their 70s okay Braco
Donald Trump is what 74 something like
that 73 similar Joe Biden's 78 will be
79 and this is what they're reduced to
yeah you're sleepy Joe no I'm not your
your president Tweety I'm telling dad we
live in the dumbest time folks we really
do the dumbest time and let me just say
one other thing about this lest you
accuse me of being offended or
scandalized by the insults I'm not at
all I have no problem with with
politicians insulting each other let me
be very clear about that they all desert
all politicians deserve to be insulted
so it's good that they're providing this
service to each other I'm a big fan of
that I'm
big fan of politicians being insulted I
think that's one of the things that
they're there for and so if they're
insulting each other I love it I'm on
board with that it's just
and yes politicians have always been
vicious to each other I'm fine with that
to quote they were quite a bit more
vicious back in the day in fact my
problem is that politicians these days
are simpletons who insult each other
like children like sixth graders now
back in the day they were at least
articulate and eloquent and creative
about it look at some of the insults
that that Teddy Roosevelt used to throw
around okay now there was a man who knew
how to insult people a few of my
favorites he said I think it was about
an author he said that he called him a
little emasculated mass of inanity okay
that's a good one infernal skunk another
good one well-meaning pinheaded and
artistic crank those are insults okay
these amateurs nowadays wouldn't know
what hit him
if old Teddy showed up with his insult
cannons loaded alright number two
famously infamously I guess I should say
part of the corona virus stimulus bill
was this enhanced unemployment measure
that gave people an extra what was it
six hundred bucks a month or a week
actually extra six hundred dollars a
week people were getting arguing on
unemployment during the krona virus the
big problem is that now people aren't
going back to work because they can make
more unemployment and I have heard this
specifically from business owners many
times that they're having trouble hiring
people back think about that imagine it
35 million people unemployed and some
business owners are having trouble
hiring people you know because these
there are a lot of people who can make
more on unemployment so just a
spectacularly stupid measure from the
government once again trying to save the
economy by incentivizing unemployment
brilliant plan well cocaine Mitch Mitch
McConnell is getting getting heat today
because he has pledged to end this
incentive and he's right to do so
you know he's sang on the next stimulus
bill there's this
this isn't gonna be in there this is
going away and that's that's the right
thing it's very easy to say oh you mean
man trying to take money away from
unemployed people businesses need
workers people and people need to work
we aren't going to have an etiquette and
economic recovery if we're literally
paying people to sit at home that's not
how you rece Park restart the engine of
the economy so it's time to end this
madness and once again that is not to
say that people should be forced to go
back to work don't accuse me of saying
that we should force we look alike or I
don't believe that all I'm saying is
that they shouldn't be paid to not work
that's the point we'll go to the third
headline in a second but first I want to
tell you about another one of our
sponsors and before I do that you know
just I should also take the opportunity
to thank our all of our sponsors
expressvpn I'm about to tell you about
all of our sponsors for supporting the
show supporting the daily wired during
this this time and thank all of you for
supporting Daily wire as well and and I
would just ask you if you you know if
you have the extra money as of course
not everybody does but if you do and
you're looking for you know a product
along the lines of one of the ones you
hear us talking about on the show then
then definitely give these sponsors a
look and consider consider supporting
them as well okay now expressvpn right
now people are online more than ever you
know spending an awful lot of time
online and I could say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market and it's one that you
definitely need especially now here's
why Express Piett VPN doesn't log your
data lots of really cheap or free VPNs
make money by selling your data to ad
companies which partially defeats the
purpose so you don't want that
expressvpn
developed a technology called trusted
server that makes it impossible for
their servers to log any of your info
also here's another fact speed you know
I've tried lots of VPNs in the past and
many of them slow down your connection
or make your device sluggish especially
for what I do for a living I can't I
can't have that I need to have the high
speeds and so that's why expressvpn is
great for me I think it'll be great
for you to something else that really
sets expressvpn apart from others is how
easy it is to use unlike other VPNs you
don't have to input or program anything
which again great for me I'm computer
illiterate even though I work on a
computer every day all day expressvpn is
the way to go so protect yourself with
the VPN that I use and I trust use my
link at expressvpn comm slash walsh
today and get an extra three months free
on a one-year package that's expressvpn
dot-com slash walsh visit expressvpn
dot-com slash walsh to learn more okay
number three I'll tell you this the
story first and then I'll show you the
picture a man named Dustin Matthew Sneed
aged 30 was arrested for setting his
grandmother's living room on fire with
two dogs inside now the dogs escaped and
we're fine grandmother was fine
everybody is fine the living room was
not so fine but that's the story and now
here's the here it is here's the mugshot
here's their he is dusted Matthew Sneed
right there
you know I got to say I didn't think
that sets grandma's living room on fire
was a look but apparently it is because
that's it that's the look like if you
went to Hot Topic and said I want to
look like someone who sets my
grandmother's house on fire that's what
they would hook you up with as if Hot
Topic has professional stylists on staff
I don't know I don't know if it works
out I haven't been there in a while
because of the shutdown I mean usually
that's where I do all my shopping anyway
so so there it is I mean I guess the
good news is though if you're a parent
and your son looks like that and he's 30
years old and so far the worst thing
he's done is set your mother's house on
fire
you'd be pretty relieved I think
actually assuming that's the worst thing
he's done based on where the bar is set
right like when the cops finally show up
at your house and say sir your son and
as soon as you hear that you're thinking
oh my god here we go here it goes and
then he finishes it with your son set
your mother's house on fire I think your
reaction would almost be relief you
would say that's it Wow okay well good I
mean not good it's not good but just I I
didn't know where this was going so all
right number four let's take a look at a
bright stop bright spot that is some
positive news this is a governor Rhonda
Santos of Florida and I do call him
governor he's well he's one who is still
governor not Emperor he hasn't been
acting like an emperor he's been acting
like a governor who actually cares about
governing and not controlling imagine
that well he's been blasted by the media
relentlessly for months and why for the
crime of doing a great job dealing with
the chrono virus you know he's that he's
done one of the best jobs if not the
best job in the entire country and for
that he's been blasted by the media
finally he stood up for himself in front
of the media and let the media have it
and this is just great stuff watch our
data is available our data is
transparent in fact actor Burks has
taught multiple times about how Florida
has the
absolute best data so any insinuation
otherwise is just typical partisan
narrative trying to be spun and part of
the reason is that because you got a lot
of people in your profession who wax
poetically for weeks and weeks about our
Florida was going to be just like New
York wait two weeks Florida's going to
be next
just like Italy wait two weeks well hell
were eight weeks away from that and it
hasn't happened not only do we have a
lower death rate while we have way lower
deaths generally we have a lower death
rate than the Acela court or DC everyone
up there we have a lower rate death rate
than the Midwest Illinois Michigan
Indiana Ohio but even in our region
Louisiana Mississippi Alabama Georgia
Florida has the lower death rate and I
was the number one landing spot from
tens of thousands of people leaving the
number one hot zone in the world to come
to my state so we've succeeded and I
think that people just don't want to
recognize it because it challenges their
narrative it challenges their assumption
so they got to try to find a boogeyman
maybe it's that there are black
helicopters circling the Department of
Health if you believe that I got a
bridge in Brooklyn I'd like to sell you
glorious absolutely glorious and
everything he said they're 100 percent
true I loved every second of that number
five finally as we have covered
extensively on the show we just talked
about governor DeSantis he's done one of
the best jobs
Governor Cuomo of New York despite being
hailed by the media as the coronavirus
Slayer the corona Slayer he has done by
far the worst job of any governor and
not just because he's had the most
deaths although he has by a mile but
because he's directly responsible for
the deaths of thousands of elderly
people in nursing homes because he
forcibly introduced the infection into
nursing homes by mandating that nursing
homes accept coronavirus patients many
many many people died as a result of
that as a direct result of that now in
spite of this rather than grilling Cuomo
and getting answers CNN has him on all
the time for these cutesy little chat
sessions with his younger brother Chris
and yesterday the cutes eNOS entered a
terminal stage watch this you had video
now before we go to break where you
wanted to encourage people to get tested
and some people are afraid it's gonna
hurt so you had video of it that I want
to show the audience if you actually
getting tested here it is there's you
you were kind of funny and they were
testing you now a few questions about
this process first of all is it true
that when you were having the test
administered you inhaled and the
doctor's finger went all the way up your
nose and got stuck and had to be
released with a tool is that true just
to deal with the Russian [ __ ] she she
wanted to comment that I have a little
button nose and she was afraid that the
swab would actually hurt because it
extended my nasal cavity the proposed
decision about the delicacy of the other
nose and that's what you know what I
understand this is the normal swab I'm
holding up here now and for everybody at
home a very valuable object there's only
one company in the entire country that
makes these up in Maine all right here's
the song is it true that this was this
swab that the nurse was actually using
on you okay stop just just just just
just up I can't even I can't watch
anymore
okay that the joke is that the q-tips
keep getting bigger you did it because
you've got a big nose and the bit goes
on for a while longer keeping keep
getting bigger and bigger q-tips
hilarious stuff right little little
comedy bit this is a news show this is a
news anchor allegedly talking to a
politician who is at the center of a
deadly scandal and this is what we get a
two-minute routine on his big nose
really embarrassing for CNN and as I
said before just it imagined the
reaction if if you know Fox News gave
Don junior you know some time some
segments to interview his dad you know
once a week and and they have these
kinds of little back-and-forth things do
you think that people on the left and
the media would would say oh there's not
so nice and so relatable no they would
say this is an assault on journalism
it's the death of journalism democracy
dies in darkness bla bla bla so on and
so forth and they'd be right in a way
and we're right in pointing that out
about CNN right now okay let's move on
to our daily cancellation and canceled
today are the makers of this bed that
I'll show you in a second according to
the Telegraph a factory in Colombia is
making hospital beds that can be turned
into a coffin if the patient dies not a
joke as far as I know they they have a
video let's let's watch the video
together so it says a Colombian designer
design company are making Hospital
cardboard hospital beds you see the
person there and then that can be easily
turned into a coffin if the patient dies
oh my gosh this is horrifying no that's
not a real dead person there I don't
think so she's just modeling it for us
and it's literally a cardboard box okay
these cardboard beds are made for people
with coronavirus
oh isn't that nice isn't that thoughtful
and if they just put a lid they put a
cardboard lid on the top of it that's
it's just it's like a it's a
refrigerator box they invented a
refrigerator box that they're putting
dead people in okay there's a design
process there what most these people
what are the people of the factory
making this what are they thinking right
now
that's my question
hospital beds and coffins are in short
supply so all right so you just combine
them okay there you go all I can say is
it's got to be a bad sign when they
transfer you into that bed I just
imagine the doctor coming in looking at
my chart and then saying okay mr. Walsch
every well everything's looking fine for
now tell you what we're just gonna move
you into this bed over here don't worry
nothing to be concerned about we won't
put the lid on yet and besides don't the
families take charge of the bodies for
the burial isn't that like usually how
this works is the family gonna want to
bury their loved one in the cardboard
box they died in I got kid ma'am I
regret to inform you that your husband
has died now would you like him in our
to-go box or did you bring your own it's
not you know I'm not laughing about it's
very serious and actually it's inspired
me because convenience is everything
right so I've invented I have come up
with a prototype it's a recliner for
your home you know like a lazy boy but
it doubles as an electric chair in case
you ever become a convicted murderer and
then no need to go through the whole
rigmarole of the death death row and
everything they just you know you just
sitting in the chair they just flip a
switch and and that's it and then they
can put you in the cardboard box so it's
kind of like a product tie-in that's
marketing for you this is getting pretty
grim I apologize anyway so the people
who came up with that are canceled for
obvious reasons pretty horrifying let's
move on to emails and you can always
email the show by becoming a daily wired
member and you get access to the mailbag
as long as well as many other perks this
is from Kelly says hey Matt I was
listening to your show yesterday about
drag story hour at public libraries it
made me wonder what you think these same
parents who take their kids to these
would think if they happen to see a
Bible study hour with a bishop or priest
reading the children I feel like I know
the answer I just like to hear you rant
about how crazy left us are thanks for
the great show well right Kelly the
answer and it's a good point but the
answer is exactly what you think the
answer is in fact
same people would not only object but
invariably they would claim that that's
a violation of church and state of the
separation of church and state because
libraries are quasi government
facilities and maybe they'd have a point
you know I don't know I I don't think
they would I think it'd be fine but but
there would be an argument at least and
that's why I would say that drag queen
story our is the same kind of thing as a
separation of separation of church and
state you know just because
progressivism is godless doesn't mean it
isn't a religion it is it is certainly a
religion with its own supernatural
beliefs in fact the the religion of
progressivism has the most implausible
supernatural belief of any religion on
earth and that they believe a man can
magically turn into a woman by putting
on a dress I'm not aware of any religion
that has a belief like that and these
drag queens story hours are like
religious rituals for those in the
religion of progressivism it's you know
it's it's not something now if you want
to do that in some private facility then
you can although actually even there I
would I would object to it in fact I
think even there it should be illegal
because it's sexual abuse it's sexual
grooming of children so even there I'm
not ok but doing it at a library is all
the worse it's just not in fact the only
way saying that this is like a religious
ritual for them I think probably cuts
them too much slack because it's
there that or it's just straight-up
sexual grooming of children probably
it's both I think in the end it's it's
it's a bit of both there is no other
reason like you want to have a story
hour you want to have kids go to the
library and hear a story great you know
libraries have been doing that forever I
remember when I was a kid we would go to
the library for story hour but you know
what we would sit in a little room and
the librarian would come in and read to
us okay that that's that's see I
understand why you have the story why do
you need a man dressed up like a woman
in a Tim Burton movie which is how all
drag queens dress for some reason why do
you need him to read it but that's the
part that doesn't make sense until you
understand it as a sort of religious
ritual and as sexual grooming of
children which is what it is okay let's
go to Aaron says hi Matt just wanted to
get your take on what seems to be an
unpopular opinion by me I know you you
homeschool so maybe you aren't the best
person to ask but I will anyway we
currently pay a lot of property taxes to
our school district in my opinion for
these taxes the school district is
responsible for providing curriculum as
well as instruction on that curriculum
since the virus has shut down schools my
elementary aged children has have been
our child has been provided curriculum
but not any virtual instruction by his
teachers I have had to cut my hours at
work in order to be his new teacher
everyone has their skill sets and being
a teacher is not one of mine I feel like
I'm doing a refund on my property taxes
since they're only doing 50 percent of
their responsibilities I should be
allocated a pro rate a part of my taxes
back if this is too harsh I should at
least be refunded for these saved
utilities and overhead costs of support
staff that have done nothing during the
shutdown what's your take on this well
Aaron you're not gonna hear any pushback
on me I'm not the guy to give you
pushback on that I absolutely agree a
hundred percent generally if you propose
any idea that has people paying less in
taxes or
getting tax money back I'm gonna be in
favor of it I don't think I've ever
heard an idea I didn't like when it
comes to people paying less you don't
even have to you don't have to go any
further you start with I have this idea
about paying less in taxes yep I'm in
favor I don't care I don't even care
what you say
everybody who wears a green shirt on
Tuesday has to pay you know those a 40
percent less in income taxes sounds good
to me
I am always a huge fan and I'll tell you
why because I'm always a huge fan of the
government making less money any way
that we can go about doing that I'm in
favor of and with this idea though the
argument in favor of it is particularly
strong so yes I agree from Steve says hi
Matt I know you tend to be anti VAX but
what do you think of these people
pledging that they won't get a corona
virus vaccine I think it's extremely
irresponsible getting a vaccine isn't
just about protecting you it's about
protecting those around you as well just
seems very selfish to me and I've seen
some conservatives I respect make these
statements well Steve I'm not sure where
you got the idea that I'm anti VAX I'm
not I don't see vaccines as something
that it makes sense to be anti or pro in
relation to them it really depends on
the vaccine and on the person getting it
and on the circumstance right doesn't it
it would be like if you asked me in my
Pro Medicine well I'm not anti medicine
certainly but that doesn't mean that I
think all medicines are good for all
people all the time obviously so the pro
or anti dichotomy doesn't make a lot of
sense or at least it's not helpful when
it comes to medicine and I don't think
it's helpful when it comes to vaccines
here's what I know about vaccines they
should be a choice I don't believe in
government forcing needles into people's
arms I just I don't like that idea at
all and people should evaluate and
research any substance before putting it
into their bodies any substance that
you're about to have injected into your
body you should know something about I
don't think that's a radical point of
view I don't think that's an anti vacuum
um and I would again I can't think of a
substance they would have injected it's
your body that I think you you shouldn't
do some research on or understand ahead
of time so that's my take you know now
on the
coronavirus vaccine it's impossible for
me to say whether I'm for it or against
it right now because it doesn't exist
and so it's theoretical it it may never
exist who knows we don't even know if it
will if it does when it does again it
should be evaluated and researched and
people should make a free choice whether
or whether to not take it if they rush
the vaccine and they have one available
like in the winter time if there's a
vaccine available in December of 2020
which I doubt but if it is I'm gonna be
pretty nervous about that I can I could
say right now I don't like the idea of
having someone rush something into
production and then me injecting it into
my body so I'm gonna be wary of that but
if a reasonable amount of time has
passed and a vaccine comes out and it's
safe and it's not being forced on me
then I might take it Shore all depends
really again I don't think vaccines are
an issue where we should be dogmatic and
I feel that way on the other side too to
be clear the people who I mean there are
people who are anti backs of course we
all know that and there are people who
would you know they're just against all
vaccines across the board they don't
like any of them without exception I
think that's also silly and I think it's
also absurdly dogmatic and that's just
not how I look at this issue I I think
it's a damn shame that something like a
vaccine has become a political
ideological issue they're there and I'm
you know I'm someone that I can easily
find the ideology in almost anything I
mean I can turn almost anything into an
ideological issue vaccines they'll or
one thing that I just don't see it I
don't see it as ideological or political
it's a vaccine it's it's a substance
right
and you find out the facts on it and the
facts are the facts and that's it that's
my that's my take
I think something a little bit more
fiery but that's all I got so then we're
gonna wrap it up there tomorrow I'll be
I'll be off but have a great Memorial
Day weekend everybody hopefully your
state has enough things open that you
can you know actually go out and enjoy
yourself and I'll talk to you next week
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]